they just recently announced and this
has nothing to do with politics I like
to take a break from politics once in a
while this is kind of a nice story they
recently announced the recipients of
this year's MacArthur Genius grant that
is a very prestigious award yeah the
deal is they give it out to people like
scientists and artists and they get a
ton of money with no strings attached
and they officially get to call
themselves a genius I mean that's pretty
great for that okay that was uh that's
our Tony our camera guy what's wrong
Tony screw those guys they snubbed me
again I'm sorry they snubbed you yeah I
don't even know I got my hopes up
anymore I'm sorry Tony why do you think
you're deserving of a MacArthur Genius
grant cuz I'm a frickin genius okay
you're a pretty good camera man but why
do you think you're a genius
all right well for one thing I brew my
own beer at home all right
the crowd likes that but Tony a lot of
people do that yeah but mine's great
okay oh and I also built a working cold
fusion generator that gives off more
energy than it consumes it defies
physics and provides unlimited green
energy yeah what the hell oh well the
key is good ingredients right you gotta
start with the best hops I get mine no
Tony I'm not talking about the beer I'm
talking did you really invent a cold
fusion generator I don't know you know
you're watching up YouTube videos to get
some pretty cool ideas well I guess if
you really built a cold fusion generator
you basically solved the planets energy
crisis and changed history now what I
solved was how to make an IPA that's
balanced and both its citrus components
and piney bank notes with a crisp hoppy
finish it's the kind of beer only a
genius couldn't make you hear that you
my concepts
Hey calm down again we're curious about
the cold fusion generator not the beer
that thing I don't know I put a magnet
in the microwave then I wrapped the
whole thing in a capillary shield with a
mid-level cathode support jacket set the
klf closure of 350 to flip the switch
and boom it kind of turned into a
floating glowing orb now it runs my
whole brewery yeah but it could run the
whole planet that sounds like a hassle
anyway try my beer no thanks we're not
gonna try your beer we don't uh I'll try
it we got some right here okay all right
oh my god Tony this is really good this
is like the best beer I've ever tasted
you are a genius you counting on behalf
of the Andy Richter and Melinda Gates
Foundation I'd like to give you this
check for ten million dollars Wow would
it on effects I quit all right we'll see
you later
[Applause]
by matter friends
you